[Music]
[Applause]
the news that broke right before we came
on to do this show this morning russell
wilson agrees to a five-year contract
extension so that's seven years for russ
the deal worth
if you throw in the entire seven years
at around 296 but all i care about is
the guaranteed money mike florio pro
football talk live co-host on peacock
with chris sims he joins us now what do
you make of the russell wilson deal mike
what stands out well i was surprised dan
that the deal isn't fully guaranteed
because that's what desean watson got
and one of the impediments to the fully
guaranteed deal is because of the nfl's
outdated funding rule that was put in
place years ago to help the players and
protect them against insolvent owners
got to put a big chunk of that money in
escrow and the understanding was the
cardinals couldn't do that or wouldn't
do that with kyler murray now here we
are kind of a tiebreaker what's going to
happen with russell wilson while we're
watching lamar jackson
russell wilson doesn't get the fully
guaranteed deal clearly new ownership of
the broncos can afford to put the full
value of the contract in escrow this i
think was about not pissing off the new
partners
of the broncos new owners because we
know the nfl owners don't like these
fully guaranteed quarterback contracts
so that's what surprised me because i
thought wilson who has always pushed for
market value
deal and he's got a client who
represents or an agent excuse me
represents one client so he can be very
aggressive and not worry about other
relationships i'm surprised you didn't
get a fully guaranteed contract i really
am
does russell wilson's contract impact
lamar jackson's negotiations at all
i think what it does dan is it makes it
harder for lamar jackson and the ravens
to get a deal done because i think the
ravens will now be emboldened in their
position we're not giving you a
five-year fully guaranteed desean watson
type contract and we know that's what
lamar wants
unless lamar jackson hires an agent this
is going to be a very hard deal to get
done and i i've been saying for years he
needs to hire an agent because you don't
just need someone dan who can negotiate
and work with the team you need somebody
who can turn around whenever you get the
best number on the table the best
package whatever the ravens will
absolutely do and not a penny more you
need somebody who can counsel the player
on the risks the benefits the rewards of
saying
no i'll just go forward with 23 million
guaranteed this year and nothing beyond
or
yeah it's probably a good idea that i
accept this offer even if it's not
exactly everything that i want
yeah i'm just trying to figure out the
timing of this because the ravens are on
the clock what do they have
nine more days to get this deal 10 more
days to get this deal done because once
the season starts
then they're not going to negotiate
anymore hey dan i think it's less than
that as a practical matter i think they
got four more days because once we get
into practice week preparation week for
week one i don't think lamar jackson is
going to want to have to mess with it
any longer unless he gets himself an
agent and if he gets himself an agent
that changes everything then the
conversations can continue he's no
longer burdened by trying to figure out
how i'm going to get ready to play
football
and how i'm going to work out a contract
with my team and look this isn't a knock
on lamar jackson i think every franchise
quarterback who's trying to get a
contract needs someone who is skilled
experienced wise understanding and can
eventually maybe speak a hard truth to a
player who has it in his head i want
more than what they're offering maybe
what they're offering is the best you're
gonna get and it's better than your
current circumstance of letting it ride
i'm talking to mike florio pro football
talk live co-host
the baker mayfield quote
that is now making the rounds went viral
as the kids like to say
is it on the record
if you do talk to a reporter but it's
not in a reporter
setting i'm trying to understand this
because you know now it's bulletin board
material for the cleveland browns well i
think we've got two questions here that
are kind of inside baseball for what we
do
the first one is
is it off the record on the record when
a sideline reporter who doesn't even
work for the panthers it's a panthers
bills game cynthia freeland is there
talking to baker mayfield is that on the
record off the record then there's the
question
did he even say it apparently he didn't
say it she said it and he agreed with
her which is a far cry from him saying i
want to f the browns up the other
question i have dan and i need to go
back and listen to the podcast where
this all first came to light it's the
around the nfl podcast and nfl media
production i think the host
kind of
took
you know a liberty with
an off-air conversation and coaxed her
into saying something that maybe she
wasn't comfortable saying on the air and
that's all because you know you know
this we always hear things
in the green room
on the bus to the stadium whatever the
case may be
and before you're going to put someone
on the spot you want to make sure
they're comfortable
telling that story on the air you don't
just drop it on them and that may have
happened here too so i think it got
dropped on her unprepared and then she
made the mistake of saying that he said
it when he clearly didn't say it she
said it and he simply agreed at most
yeah i was trying to understand sort of
the paper trail on this and you're right
this is you know inside baseball in our
world of what we deal with but
baker came out and said look i never
said it
and you know so now it's he said she
said and but hey dan here's the big
takeaway i had he never said it
but he still wants to do it
it's not that he didn't think it right
john gruden's situation with the nfl
and i think there was talk of maybe
trying to have private arbitration here
with the
the lawsuit here so what what is the
basis of john gruden's suit and the
likelihood he could win this and what
that means for his future
john green's lawsuit against the nfl and
the commissioner is very simple he's
arguing that they took private
confidential information that was part
of the washington commander's
investigation peeled off a few pages
deliberately gave that information to
the media in order to put mark davis the
owner of the raiders in a position where
he had to push john gruden out because
you know what if this stuff never ends
up in the wall street journal the new
york times maybe mark davis says hey
these were emails that were sent years
ago he wasn't working for me i'm not
going to be pushed to fire this guy or
ask him to resign i'm keeping him so it
gets leaked publicly and davis has to
get rid of him so gruden who owns the
fact that he sent the emails is
basically saying the nfl engineered this
process deliberately and wrongfully in
order to get me out of a job the
arbitration comes up dan because any
time the nfl gets sued by a former coach
a current coach anyone who's signed a
contract with the team
they try
to run it through this arbitration
process because it's secret
it's rigged in their favor how can it
not be the commissioner's the one who
presides over the process how can you
not have a clear bias when the person
who
is employed by the teams is the one
who's resolving claims against the teams
they shouldn't want that the
commissioner shouldn't want to be in
that spot but he is every time and it's
going to be an issue in the flores
lawsuit it's an issue in gruden's
lawsuit now gruden won so far brewton
has won the argument of whether or not
the case goes to arbitration but the nfl
history tells us we'll appeal that to
the highest court in the land delay this
gruden case for two three four years
while the league tries desperately to
keep this case out of the public eye if
it's in open court we get to find out a
lot of stuff if it's in arbitration we
may never know the details of how those
emails got out
john gruden coach in the nfl again no
absolutely not no way no way first of
all his time with the raiders
was not impressive his draft picks and
he was running the show there not mike
mayok i mean mike mayhawk's basically
setting the table gruden is calling the
shots a disaster and dan even though
it's wrong
when you sue the shield
when you sue the commissioner and put
them in this position
of having to fight and maybe eventually
settle
how do you expect it's wrong but how do
you expect when there's an opening with
one of 32 teams and there are plenty of
qualified candidates
how do you ever expect to get one of
those jobs again i could see him landing
at a college if he's content trying to
teach 18 19 20 year olds i don't know he
would be
but the chances of him be an nfl head
coach ever again i think are somewhere
between slim and none and far closer to
none
it feels like college football maybe a
second-tier
pac-12
maybe sec something like that does that
make more sense the fact that he was at
the little rock arkansas
touchdown club and arkansas is a top 20
team so i thought you know maybe he's
just there and
you know a not so subtle message of i'm
here if you need me but
he said all the things like hey i i go
to church and i've been married for 31
years i got three great kids and
i did these bad things with the email
inexcusable but is he hireable
for university
i think it would have to be the right
university that has
the
the right
location
demographics
boosters and and basically folks who are
willing to say john gruden means we're
going to win
so we're willing to forgive and forget
we're willing to overlook all this other
stuff we're willing to do the mental
gymnastics necessary to come to the
conclusion that just because somebody
goes to church or claims they do and has
been married for 31 years that must mean
all is well and everything's fine and
it's not going to be a problem and at
the end of the day we just want to win
he'll come work for us and we won't have
to pay him a ton of money and maybe
we'll be a better program i think that's
his best shot if he's willing to do it
and you know what if he could go to a
college program and have some dramatic
impact and turn it around
i don't know maybe at that point the nfl
starts paying attention again i doubt it
though that it's ever going to be enough
to get him back to the nfl i'll leave
you with this we talked about this
yesterday
if you're gonna have a bargain like the
the bengals were a long shot as far as a
bargain you know the odds to
be great this year
so
and most people take in the colts
because
you know the those are still kind of
long odds uh paulie took the steelers
but
is there a team there you go boy there's
value there if you want to take a flyer
on a team this year that team is
well i agree with paulie on the steelers
i definitely agree on the steelers i've
seen them at 10 to 1 to win their
division which to me is astounding and i
know from being in and around pittsburgh
for
my entire life any time that the
steelers are overlooked and disregarded
that's just one of the ingredients that
helps them especially under mike tomlin
have a pretty good team you're throwing
brian flores a second head coach as your
linebackers coach they're going to be
better than people think in the nfc i
i talked about this earlier today i
think the vikings are going to win the
nfc north i think with an offensive head
coach to replace the mess that they've
had in recent years revolving door of
coordinators they've got the talent on
the offensive side of the ball the
defense doesn't need to be much better
and it was horrible last year they can
be surprisingly good
i uh i i thought the vikings would make
the playoffs this year i don't have a
stronger feel like you do there but like
the browns are plus 5 000. thousand
seems like a decent
decent number to jump on for them the
raiders at plus four thousand dolphins
plus like i don't know if there's a team
that could be the bengals this year i
guess
that's the better way to put this hey
dan in the afc look at the afc i if i'm
the bills right now
i'm thinking what in the hell did we do
to get ourselves in the position where
we're wearing the target we haven't been
to a super bowl in 30 years and we got
the target with 13 true contenders so
every team except the texans jaguars and
jets is a contender in the afc
what a meat grinder that's going to be
it's going to be fun for us
as fans but it's going to be
nerve-wracking to try to put your name
on a prediction i don't know what the
hell is going to happen in the afc
when
or does the story of tom brady's absence
come out
i do not know
dan all i know is he's back
and better than ever okay and ready to
go and he won't be leaving again until
he does what about his podcast with jim
gray and larry fitzgerald oh you mean
with the hard-hitting questions that
he's going to get every week from jim
gray his good buddy i mean that sounded
sarcastic mike no that's not being
sarcastic at all you know that's
it is must listen because you never know
what he's going to say that's where he
said never say never about unretiring
less than a week after he retired so you
definitely have to listen to let's go
did you almost interview aaron donald
with the ground rules you couldn't ask
him about the helmet swinging i i was i
was not afforded an opportunity to
interview aaron we weren't either we
weren't on that that guest list hey dan
i had i can't i'm not going to name the
player but we had one earlier this year
where there was some reason he was in
the news i can't even remember why and
they tried to say you can't ask about
that and i told matt casey the pft live
producer cancel it i'm not doing it i'm
not i'm just not because it's not a
superstar for a superstar at least try
to negotiate you know we got to ask the
question it's up to you to answer it but
i'm a hack i'm a hack anyway but i'm a
hack if i don't ask that question with
this guy i just said can't
are you kidding me bye-bye go sell your
product somewhere else
well who knows you could get a kyler
murray interview like i had at the super
bowl a couple of years ago
well
that was that was uh that was memorable
and the fact that it was live
and you can't hide
and there's a crowd there we had a
studio audience i got his dad all the
way across the room i'm interviewing his
dad now because kyler didn't want to
talk and i'm going
what the hell am i doing have you ever
had a pr person interrupt you during an
interview though that actually happened
yesterday is this aaron donald tour the
pr person
it wasn't live but it was live to tape
they're all live to tape if they're not
live
actually interjecting saying he's not
here to talk about that move along well
i had it happen with tonya harding
i was interviewing her
and i started asking her about the nancy
kerrigan and then she said hold on a
second paul wants to talk to you
i don't know who paul is
paul comes on and said what are we doing
here dan
and i said i'm doing an interview paul
like what are you doing here
but it hasn't happened recently what
paul it happened two months ago when we
taped tom brady and we you guys were
rolling you and tom were having a great
conversation we had a time limit and all
of a sudden the
person
said uh we're gonna have to wrap this up
pretty soon it was a quick jump in but
brady's like we're good we're good and
brady to his credit kept going
we had
99.9 of the interviews we do are live
because i i do better i like that
feeling but we did brady because it was
on his schedule and i got we had 10
minutes and then we got to 10 minutes
like a little bit after 10 minutes and
then i ask a question
and then the pr person jumps in
and says uh that's it we're done and
then tom goes wait he's got three hours
on his show to fill
and i thought okay and and and then i
asked him about you know could he go get
his super bowl rings how long would it
take him to get him and then he answered
and then that was it like i had to i was
done with the interview because i was
told so she did jump in
had it been live she would have jumped
in
that that's what it's just
i i've gotten texts from a producer oh
yeah you're telling us to rap right
that's the way you do it you don't jump
in it's just amazing well fritzy fritzy
gets that where i'm interviewing i think
we're rolling and then fritz seal go uh
we got to wrap up um he'll send me a uh
an email gotta wrap up hey you gotta
wrap up and i'm blown through the stop
sign because i think this guy's having a
good time talking to us and
poor fritzy he he he faces the brunt of
that it's a nice note that gets
increasingly more terse says 30 seconds
paulie's telling me we got to go to
breakfast
mike i gotta go yeah yeah you know what
my pr person is telling me i gotta go
too mike florio pro football talk long
thank you mike back after this